now did you watch the I'm sure the fight
between Ortiz and sure did dude yeah
which think I think that Ortiz is forty
and I think that John T Wilder hits like
everybody says impossibly hard and minoo
people always say that to me Deontay
Wilder camp box like he's not a boxer
which is compared to Tyson Fury
technique-wise
it's smash again did you watch fire to
see the highlight I did watch the fire
what's fight and I don't lose every
round to get out class technical
technical got outclassed yeah lost every
round that's right let me come with
right hand that's right yes that's the
problem is that that fundamentally he's
not on the same level it's not fury T's
or Josh no but he has that gift from the
hell of a easy gift he's got that how do
you hear train it you can't make one
mistake your board looked like was that
Ortiz in the sounds around got tired he
looked like he was standing there and he
was blocking then he just for a second
he dropped his hands he looked why the
whole time some was like you reset and
then boom water Jarrett losing every
[ __ ] around but that's true III just
him very curious leather manly tech
technical like Ortiz definitely the I'm
sorry
while there's definitely the worst out
of three there's no question is the most
useful tool it's nuts crazy can shut the
game down
I don't know III it's but it makes the
division very exciting because Dion
towada can still lose if you avoid that
right hand big if no one has it big if
no one no one has you and fury do it no
rate as he is free didn't avoid it I
know I get a draw I look you see that
he's got he's got his hands waiting for
it all night in range that was the only
he just got a little tired there just
got up for a second I look pretty good
man that's that's more Wilders skilled
level then Ortiz taking it easy this era
it's right down the pipe right down the
pipe booth and just couldn't get back up
oh you know who I did it
oh Jesus his hands are up you know there
yet fury wild or happen in February for
sure enough you do have to yep great
fight great fight
whoa Furies
slight favorite we licked up this
morning below the belt slight favorite
cuz I'll see Wilder you know that right
hands gonna land while there has so much
self belief for a guy who knows he's the
know technically he's not on their level
but he's the nicest guy ever a bat he's
so cool you know who was awesome I did a
food truck with Maz little on Friday
yeah you told me it's great man yeah
it's the good days special guy really
special guy introvert right does it like
the fame takes it personally no not
really no no he he looked like he was he
looked like when he was about to fight
Askren he when he had his hands man's
back and he looked at him and just
smiled he looked like he was he was
gonna [ __ ] love ya he was just angry
no no he he knew he was gonna be all
avoid that wrestles and fight angry he's
but he knew he's gonna be doing so long
yeah you didn't care he's got just tools
such a stud such as such a good dude
yeah great conversation ah if you fight
to us man he's not going to he's not
he's not according to him he doesn't
want to get us the food-truck diary but
he gives three other options that he's
gonna do both sides
cuz he's bitter agree with me he talks
about in the end ever he's bigger than
the title say I don't care about title
cuz I'm gonna for big fights money fight
vote neither those guys are money fight
you well I was in my cash meds hearings
and a girl I'll sit across from who
makes those jeans I go I don't know and
she goes I think they're really sexy and
I won't tell my boyfriend to spend money
on jeans and then her boyfriend and I
looked at her boyfriend and I went you
gotta buy these jeans too I'm naked and
famous but I like naked a famous yeah
well the reason I buy Naked and Famous
the reason I buy him a story
nope I'm in New York City handsome guy
gets out his wife and her baby of a cab
and the guy looks at me and I'm wearing
I'm just wearing like a [ __ ] jacket
and he goes I was very handsome jeans
very handsome and I went that's weird to
say to me dude your big handsome guy you
got your wife and kid I don't know you
I'm about to take your cab what do you
mean he goes negative famous and I go
they are how did you know that because
you can't see my man he goes that was
the stuff I designed it oh I didn't know
that yeah he designed them oh wow you
know you're addict you know your product
no yeah if you
so now I don't get oh that's cool do you
favor you doing for Thanksgiving dude we
got to show Wednesday night we got our
show well [ __ ] um sorry I don't see Jake
um sing for me now hold on no pjq
anything don't be a wonderful night oh
thanks for coming out branzino 10
minutes at paddle now introduce the rest
of comedy house celebrity theater in
Phoenix come out I think we're probably
gonna sell out with the bed that's gonna
be making that up but no that's because
it's already it's a big its event I'm at
the headliner of the larger event
slabber theater and and then Wilbur
theater in Boston I think I'm her first
New Year's right yeah and then I'm gonna
then I'll go to Boston for New Year's
you you know it was not cold in New York
50 degrees I play tennis twice [ __ ] Salt
Lake City was freezing it was it's
freezing freezing [ __ ] freezing for
me I don't know about you the only thing
that turns me into a coward is united's
a fatigue turns us into cowards like who
is that Lombardi said that yeah fatigue
makes cowards of men I think only the
curl the cold turns me into a coward I
just don't like grew up in the only
thing cold is your ally I grew up in the
cult dude you were him to call the
rebels called
I was born in the gold oh I just don't
like it it doesn't bother me I don't
like it you do okay when you play
football in the cold lock handle if
you're hiring fine but I hate when they
go it's football weather once called out
no it's [ __ ] [ __ ] says that one of
those guys player hate why do those guys
why do you see those guys just wearing
no sleeves that's just a statement [ __ ]
you know they can feel stuff like I
don't think I all you guys want to be
all bundled on but when you're freezing
when it's they put like green bay I know
those guys are crazy
they're nuts but go to Whitney Cummings
up miss story and this is I didn't know
that I was being [ __ ] videotaped but
this is what she videotapes me when I
don't know what's going on
she [ __ ] with me yeah keep going you
news youth I did not I did
[Music]
hi guys behind me look at this town
oh she she's always in there giving
massages huh was it nice amazes great
she's amazing she always offers it now
he's turning dead dude
she's the best masseuse I've ever been
I've never what's your name um [ __ ] it's
gets tied the best though I can't
believe I've casted I wanted to know
it's called happy ending that's crazy
yeah we're you getting massaged
discipline yeah and I got to do it I
keep telling I'm gonna do a podcast
which I will a copy of the happy things
I'm [ __ ] how do I not joke it's gonna
be worse massage yeah you won't have
been massaged I'll let you know where
massage cast is that right yeah she's
great she's a great girl is that it yeah
join him yeah joy joy that's right she's
so sorry joy she's so nice she's always
in there she's the best at what I always
past I was like I'm good on this massage
break going well another fan submitted
stories that they want to see you guys
react to this f-150 vs. the Tesla truck
mm-hmm and it's the Tesla truck pulling
f-150 how is that I'm sorry to ask is
that Tesla truck an open bed there no
okay this close bed I think I can't it
opens and closes oh well it opens but
it's not an open bet and I see say
inside like I can't like throw something
in it from here right is it closed the
look site is closed there yeah thing is
closed because it opens our I love it
they said I'll buy one for sure
well here's the problem with this I
don't need to see any comments so first
of all that's not a four-wheel-drive
f-150 it's a rear-wheel drive f-150 the
front tires aren't moving
so it's basically just pulling a truck
with no payload and up a hill and also
got you posted up to write what I also
got the jump on the truck cuz it's
electric it was going first yeah yeah
it's very strange
what's what's Neil deGrasse Tyson say
about it badass
Tesla likes to embarrass things but if
the f-150 is rear-wheel drive with nope
there you go no payload the weight on
the rear axle is greatly reduced
offering only mild trash from a Tesla to
overcome this kind of s'more about
physics of friction than engine power
cry cuz it yeah yeah yeah how there's no
load in the back and it's that's
two-wheel drive f-150 the engines in the
front so that back is gonna be so light
oh I say yeah oh I see so okay it's
nothing that you know like your kids car
when he pulled back you know how did you
know it was a form was not a four-wheel
drive I'm looking I'm like the tires
moving the front ones weren't moving it
you know like though they should right
that's not it was from Kalyn
yes ok from Kalyn [ __ ] yeah that's
weird I was gonna say it's [ __ ] when
you see my back ripple and I pull myself
up like a champ like a champ through 30
times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift